So the midterms are two days away,
and that means forgive us.
The Iowa
caucuses are about 14 months away.
14 months.
But that is the fact that Donald Trump
is making sure that we don't lose
sight of
we're
winning big, big, big
in the Republican Party
for the nomination
like nobody's ever seen before.
Let's say there it is Trump at 71
Ron to sanctimonious at 10%
Mike Pence
at 70 Mike's doing better than I thought.
In case you missed it,
that was a
not so subtle jab
at two presidential potential
presidential rivals,
Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and his former vice
president, Mike Pence,
at a rally last night in Pennsylvania.
CNN is reporting
that Trump could announce a campaign
as soon as November 14th.
That is a week from tomorrow, which he
all but confirmed last night.
Everybody, I promise you,
in the very next very, very, very short
period of time,
you're going to be so happy
if you're announcing
your presidential bid in November,
two years
before the next presidential election.
Is that a sign of strength
or a sign of weakness
that maybe he's trying to
put a stake in the ground right now?
Well, honestly, it's
not that far off the norm.
Because we have seen it.
You know,
it's typically been,
I guess, the new year, January,
at least, I think.
I mean, yes, years ago
was like was a lot farther out.
But I mean, honestly,
these Republicans have started running
for president already.
I mean, Mike Pompeo has a team in Iowa.
There are rumblings
that DeSantis could be planning
trips to early states.
He was very careful
in how he handled his endorsements
in early primary states.
For example,
he stayed out of some critical New
Hampshire primaries
that I know
from my reporting
that some of the candidates
would have really liked him
to weigh in on.
And he didn't
because he didn't want to make
anybody mad
in a state that he might want to win,
you know, come.
You know,
I guess
just over a year from now, right
when we're looking at the Iowa caucus
in the New Hampshire primary.
But the reality is for Trump,
I mean, if he look, you saw
I mean,
there's giving me flashbacks
about you guys
to those debates stages
that we saw in 2015
where it's Donald Trump in the center
kind of knocking out Republican candidate
after Republican candidate one at a time.
We were laughing about
Ron de sanctimonious
because the thing that Trump
can do
better than anyone
in the context of a pure
political campaign is sense weakness,
identify it
and convince people that it's true
And he's already
starting to do that with the.
Yeah.
I mean, he certainly has that ability.
I mean, there's the sort of pettiness
around this nickname.
I mean, it's sort of like Real Housewives
level petty.
And I mean that as a compliment
in so many ways.
Listen, I think you get points
for bringing up The Real Housewives
I think to your
question, it's
both a sign of strength and weakness.
Right.
He is strong in the sense
that Republican voters
emotionally are very very attached
to Donald Trump.
He convinced
70% of Republican voters that Joe Biden's
election was illegitimate,
that he's not a legitimate president.
I do think he is slightly worried about
the field of people who could
enter this race.
It could be wise to sort this up.
And I think that worry
is impacting the timing.
Listen to this.
Here's here's what's about to happen.
He picked up on you
notice DeSantis and Pence.
DeSantis is poised
to have an enormous victory
on Tuesday night
getting reelected as governor of Florida.
That is likely to be the outcome there.
Mike Pence is about to go on a book tour
and roll out his new
book and be at the center
and catch the timing on the book.
Release. It's November 15.
Well, exactly.
That is exactly one day
after this possible announcement, right.
This blow to date of November 14th
that they're circling around
as a potential announcement.
So he clearly I agree with you.
I think that shows clear concern
or at least he's getting to work.
You know, for the last two years,
it's been Donald Trump
on a sort of greatest hits road show.
And now we're getting the new material.
The new album is out.
And he's
the new material is very much like
like, oh, mature early.
It worked for him in 20, 15,
as Casey was just pointing out.
And so what this signals to me is
a we all
I think assume
he is going to get into this race
and he wants to get in early
because he defines the playing field.
That's a part of his political success.
Better than most campaign.
I don't think we should also forget
the fact
that he is under
significant investigation
that could lead him
significant legal liability.
And this
has to be driving some decision
making and announcing early.
Remember we were talking about him
potentially announcing
during the midterm season
because he wants to
use the investigations as a way to say
this is a witch hunt against me,
etc., etc., etc.
He held off here, though,
because he got urged
by Republican leaders
not to come forward during the midterms.
It could turn this race about him,
make the midterm environment about him.
But if he announces next week,
there could be a Georgia runoff
in December
where Herschel Walker and Raphael Warnock
could be facing off in a runoff there.
How does it impact
that race will be a question.
I mean, to your point
about the investigations,
the January six committee
has subpoenaed Trump.
They've asked him to produce documents
and testimony by,
take a guess, November 14th.
So all the stars are aligning.
And if you're Donald Trump,
who often uses
these kind of investigations
and the specter of criminal prosecution
as a political tool Right.
That is useful for him.
But if you are Herschel
Walker in Georgia,
I'm not sure that I mean, establishment
and Republicans in Washington,
particularly Mitch
McConnell, are just
going to be apoplectic about this,
especially if we're
in a Georgia runoff situation.
But if you're Donald Trump,
I mean, he's not talking about
going straight into a general election.
He's talking about
going into a Republican primary.
And from a political perspective,
those investigations
play right into his hands
in the context of a Republican primary.
And the other thing
is, I've actually spent
a lot of time lately
talking to people around
Ron DeSantis,
as well as Republican strategists
who are kind of looking at
and trying to figure out
honestly, many of them
which camp to
which which trained to jump on
who do they want to work for
in a potential Republican primary. Right.
And a lot of them have pointed me
to the fact that if Trump gets in before
Ron DeSantis, who really is
like the big kind of other elephant
in the room at the moment,
then every single thing
that Ron DeSantis does
is not about Ron DeSantis.
It's about Donald Trump.
He is willing to take on Donald Trump
if it becomes it
accomplish
Is what Trump was able to do so
well that led him to the White House.
It just makes it all about him into the
conversation for sure.